DirecTV has decided to drop Newsmax
you know I love Newsmax I've appeared on
many Newsmax shows this after DirecTV
decided to drop oan another Channel I
like a lot appeared on a lot of oan
shows
why did they do it well according to
DirecTV they say they're doing it
because
Newsmax asked for rate increases which
quote would have led to significantly
higher costs that we would have had to
pass on to the broad customer base
doesn't
seem very credible to me when I think of
the relatively low carry costs for all
of these conservative channels and the
fact that plenty of TV stations
raise their costs as inflation increases
as their business changes
and DirecTV never seems to to cancel the
liberal channels
DirecTV only which is owned by at T only
cancels the conservative ones